thanks everybody for coming out that's
great too great to be here I hope this
is is interactive so if you have any
questions or I say something silly feel
free to to to stop me and raise your
hand ask questions I think we are
recording this so if we get if you can
if you raise your hand I'll give you a
mic otherwise I if I remember I'll
repeat your question I'm a developer not
a not not someone who goes around giving
talks all the time so I'll always always
had the most polished presentations but
I know a lot about bigquery I wrote the
book on bigquery Paul's got a copy if
anybody wants to wrestling for it so I'm
happy to answer any kind of questions I
can go on at length about bigquery I'll
probably bore you all to to tears so
feel free to like to start nodding off
and and that'll take that as a signal
that I should start wrapping things up
so what am I going to talk about today
talk about what what is bigquery I guess
first of all how many people have used
bigquery anyone okay so we have a few
users how many people don't know what
bigquery is a couple okay some what we
got some honest honest folks here well
hopefully nice next ten minutes you'll
you'll you'll know what bigquery is I'm
going to show a couple demos of just how
how how fast it is how what kind of
stuff it can do I'm gonna go in a little
bit of the architecture I can go I can
go at more depth depending on what
people are interested in and then just
sort of also have a couple slides on on
on how you can use it and the kinds of
things you can do with it and then
finally I have a demo that you know I
guess you guys are in the in the city of
Spotify so I thought I would I would
come up with a demo that was that was
appropriate so I have a playlist data
set that I'm gonna use to build sort of
music recommendations in ipython at the
end and then hopefully have plenty of
times for Question and Answer you can
ask questions about bigquery about
Google cloud working at Google
what I think of Sweden American politics
I may not answer but but hopefully
hopefully won't ask me anything about
American politics so so I stole these
slides from some ones on the sales team
and I didn't don't always know when you
have to click multiple times to get it
to get everything so so what is bigquery
it's it's it's a big data analytics
engine it lets you run sequel queries in
the cloud over your data that's stored
in the cloud and it doesn't matter how
big that data is it doesn't matter what
what kinds of query queries you want to
do it's easy to use it's got open open
interfaces we have a REST API to to
access that we also have a number of
tools that that we provide you can
access access it through and there's
some third-party tools as well and it
should be familiar to people that are
familiar with databases you can share
share your data you can easily easily
import your data because when you're
when you have large data in the cloud it
becomes really important just how how
you get your data there because you
don't want to have to keep moving data
around so we like think of it as a data
warehouse some data warehousing people
people coming for a traditional data
warehousing background may be like well
you guys don't have XY and Z perhaps
perhaps we don't but I think a lot of
the reasons that people use data
warehouses you can use bigquery for it's
fully managed you'd have to worry about
spinning up instances you don't have to
worry about how large those instances
are you have to worry about if if disks
crash or things crash if things crash
I'll get a page or one of my co-workers
will get a page and and hopefully we'll
fix it we'll fix it quickly if you've
got petabytes of data we can we can we
can take your petabytes of data as I
mentioned has has a nice equal interface
I will show just how how fast it is in a
couple of minutes and I think it was the
register that calls this analytics as a
service and the the the acronym is ass
so we don't always use it the acronym as
much as we use like
for mrs. service but but you could call
it that so they're not what's under the
hood you know we we run your queries in
parallel that's how we make it fast
Google a long time ago decided that
scale-up wasn't gonna wasn't going to
work they didn't want to buy actually
they at the time they couldn't afford to
buy expensive million dollar database
machines that every time you need
something bigger you have to buy
something in order of magnitude more
expensive so they said well we can apply
brain power to to scaling out rather
than rather than scaling up and this
isn't you know these days that's like of
course duh but ten years ago it was it
it was it was pretty revolutionary and
you know the goal was to to be able to
to read a terabyte of data per second we
can we can pretty much get get close to
that on your data and that's a shared
cluster so basically everybody is all
the queries are running in the same
cluster when we have some nice nice
mechanisms to keep to keep your queries
from stomping on somebody else's queries
but it also means that you know you get
a slice of a giant cluster machine of
machines rather than having to spin up a
medium sized cluster or have to deal
with all the hardware requirements for
the for the the queries you need at the
time so it's got a rich sequel sequel
language that extends extend some of the
things you can do a normal sequel with
with nested and repeated fields so it
doesn't have to be just purely
rectangular data it does have a JSON
JSON query so if you--if you have fields
that have just raw JSON you can you can
do sort of JSON path type queries from
those IP address IP parsing regular
expressions kinds of things that are
they can be really expensive to do in in
a normal relationship relational
database that has indices for example it
doesn't matter
we also have a streaming ingestion API
where you can just give us send us your
data just send a an HTTP POST request as
your data comes in and you can you can
send up to a hundred thousand rows per
second per table so you know we have
some customers that are actually that's
not enough for them so they send a whole
bunch or they they shard that over a
whole bunch of tables and that I
generally just just works you can also
adjust your data from cloud storage or
via Hadoop or via Google Cloud dataflow
or sort of a number of other other
mechanisms there's some third-party
connectors to to allow you to to access
your data so if you use fuse R or
ipython pandas there's some nice
integrations there there's a Hadoop
connector so you can use bigquery tables
as either a source or sink for your for
your Hadoop jobs there's also an ODBC
connector for people who might be sort
of old-school they like their Microsoft
technologies and they're gonna they're
going to use them etc and we also allow
you to to join data from anywhere so
it's a single namespace so you might
have a table that you want to share with
with a customer or with a group of
customers you can create a view of your
underlying data and allow your customers
to query over query over that data just
by just by updating the Akal it's it can
be pretty pretty easy and also you can
you can do ETL on an bigquery so we we
do have the ability to to write large
data sets back in in parallel so let's
say you need to do data cleaning you
need to coerce your data from from one
format to another you need to
deduplicate you can do all these things
within within bigquery and bigquery has
essentially unlimited storage if you're
going to store more than I don't know 10
petabytes or something let us know
but you know it at Google there are
people who are like we're like you know
you say I need I need some any disk
quota and they say how much you need me
as I see a petabyte oh I thought you I
think needed a lot of quota like it's
it's it's generally not a not a big deal
but we do replicate it
you know geographically and and and
store it in an encoding that's that
that's durable so so we can we can store
your petabytes of data without without
without losing it um it also means that
you you don't need to throw away data at
least one definition of Big Data that I
heard was Big Data is when it becomes
less expensive to keep your data than it
is to figure out what you need to throw
away so we hope that we're enabling that
kind of model where you just accumulate
data you might need it you might need it
again and if you don't it's not costing
you very much to to keep it around and
and it's also that all that old data is
immediately accessible you don't have to
readjust it read you know change the
format you can just run queries over
over all of your data
ok so I'll do a little demo just to kind
of show how how fast the query is and
hopefully it's fast tonight all right so
this is a benchmark data so that it
actually comes from from Wikipedia has
basically one row for every Wikipedia
view per day of every Wikipedia topic so
we have it we actually have some very
large very large data and this this is
just a small slice of that data so this
has 1 million rows of the the Wikipedia
data set and that was cached and you
probably don't want to see the cached
data because it's not very impressive to
to run a cached query very fast
there we go no cash results there we go
so two seconds to do a million rows
that's probably probably not not not
impressing anybody you know a million
rows isn't cool you know what's cool a
billion rows how long is a billion rows
take 4.7 seconds so not bad we went up
we wanted three orders of magnitude and
and just over doubled doubled the time
we have some bigger we have some bigger
data here how about a hundred billion I
don't have a movie quote to go with a
hundred billion but honourably is
another two orders of magnitude it's a
lot of data this is about it's going to
scan about four and a half terabytes of
data and there we go seven point four
seconds so as reasonably fast hopefully
hopefully somebody is is suitably
impressed but okay so that's so the
query that we were running was actually
running a regular expression over every
single row to find things that had that
match Google and title and it's doing an
aggregation over those but you may say
well what about joins like I want to I
want to do joins so so this is the same
this is a 1 billion row data set and I'm
joining against itself and I'm doing a
group by here not to to decrease the
number but because I don't want to get a
joint explosion so when you join the
relational algebra says if if there's
multiple values or multiple rows with
the same value on each side of the join
you get the cross product of those I
know I don't want it I don't want to
expend an expansion I just want to get
just see how fast the joint is I
probably should have started this before
I before I started started my spiel
because this this will take usually 20
or 30 seconds sometimes it's a little
slower but so this is this is this is
joining two billion row tables and so
when I do the group by the one on the
table on the right it shrinks down to
about 200 million rows so it's a billion
rows against 200 million rows and there
we go
twenty two twenty two seconds twenty two
point nine seconds and as shuffling
shuffling that data it's sending it
across the network and and then doing
the same same sort of aggregation so so
big query it's pretty fast I didn't need
to do anything special to get that kind
of speed all you need to do is actually
you get you can run the same the same
query and and validate that that's that
you get the same same sort of speeds if
you have your own data you can use that
or you can I believe it I believe this
this data sets public I use that for the
for the for the book oops I want to
share I want to present three buttons
that we throw on
okay so here's a here's a chart of what
performance looks like and this is I
this was from the book this is from last
last spring Celeste it's about a year
old since then our clusters have gotten
much much larger and and and we added
some some technology to make joins much
faster so you see here and it looks like
a straight line but this is a log linear
line so if it's a straight line it's
actually increasing as little as the as
the log so if we go from from two
seconds to scan a thousand rows to to
eight seconds to scan seven orders of
magnitude larger and then four four
joins you do see we hit a kind of an e
here at the it adjoins this was with the
old joint technology because I just did
I said it looks about right that's just
it says 1 billion is is is 30 seconds so
bigquery is based on is an
externalization of an internal
technology called Dremel Dremel is a
tool that's been used in Google for
about about ten years the the inventors
of Dremel they said what if the
constraints of normal databases means
one of the harder the one of the hardest
things and in a normal in building a
normal database is you spend a lot of
your time worrying about table scans you
don't want to do a table scan because
table scans are slow every time you do a
table scan you have to read all your
data off disk discs are slow memory is
much faster you want to be able to have
indices and and and build up heuristics
about your data so that you you can do
is to disk read as possible and so they
said what if we just made us that every
query was a table scan if every query
read every row could we just make a
table scan really fast if we made a
table scan fast are there cool things
that we could do by leveraging Google's
technology and an infrastructure scale
so they built they built Tremmel and the
way it essentially works is there's a
root server we call it a mixer some
intermediate servers and some some leaf
servers the
that that that do the work so when you
when you execute a query when you when
you run a query the the root server
partitions that query up into the source
the sources of your data so if you have
you know we may store your table on ten
thousand ten thousand files so we will
send the sort of that till the the leaf
servers to read to read just one of
those files and we can send one of the
nice things about sequel is that sequel
is is sort of nicely parallel
parallelizable it's it's it's
essentially functional you can split it
up into multiple pieces do them in
parallel and then the hard part is
aggregation so that's when the your
intermediate servers come in so the the
queries flow down to the leaf servers
the aggregations flow flow back up let's
say you're doing a some the the the leaf
servers will compute the the some of the
data they know about and the
intermediate servers will compute the
some of the data they know about are the
some of the the partial sums and then
the root will compute the total sum so
you can you can split things apart
nicely build them take them back
together there's some things that are
tricky distinct distinct numbers of
values are tricky and then joins joins
are tricky when you have two large data
sets so when you do when you have two
large data sets what actually happens is
we do a hash partitioning so we'll read
the data we will assign a hash value to
to your join keys and then it will send
all of the data that that match all the
rows that match that join key to the
same server I'm probably going into this
more in more detail I'm happy to answer
questions about about this of people if
people have had them and then we store
it in in actually the successor to GFS
which is called Colossus at Google it's
it's very similar to to GFS it's you
think that is storing your data on
hundreds of thousands of disks so one
disk one disk is is slow but if you can
read on if you can read from a hundred
thousand disks in parallel and that's
pretty fast
so it can leverage the technology that
we have at Google called called Colossus
so that so that you really can read from
from a massive numbers of disks at a
time so that you that's essentially what
allows the how do you do a table scan
super fast and their goal was to do to
do a terabyte a second and on some some
queries we can we can actually we can
actually get that I mean the query that
we saw was what seven seconds eight
seconds to do to do four and a half
terabytes
so and that was also doing a bunch of
process things at regular expression
processing and that's also sharing the
cluster with a bunch of other clients
yes yes so the question was was whether
the query planning takes takes place in
the root server or if I can talk about
the query planning can't talk too much
about the query planning other than to
say that we don't do much great planning
the it's sort of one of the nice things
about this massive massively parallel is
is that you don't need in order to get
things fast you don't need to be smart
you just need to have lots of hardware
and there's clearly some you know some
some things that are that are not as
true about that and we are we are we are
investing in some query planning it's
like we started and we had this
amazingly fast amazingly fast system
that there's a couple of like corner
cases that because it's a totally
different architecture the way people
expect things to behave sometimes don't
work the way people would the way people
would expect certain types of queries
that are fast in relational database
they may be more difficult for us to do
the count unique is count distinct is is
is a perfect example and but as as we're
sort of becoming a more mature
technology we realized that our there
are some of these nice to have things
that we need to go back and do it so
there are we're getting smarter so our
service is getting smarter we're
building a lot of
more intelligence into the service and a
lot more predictability and that's you
know one of the things that we're really
focusing on now is being able to make
sure that if you ran a query yesterday
and it took ten seconds I can run it
tomorrow and it's going to take ten
seconds plus or minus that's a
reasonable Delta hope that answered your
question so the other the other thing
that helped out was that that helped us
to table scans very fast is it's
column-oriented storage and
column-oriented storage is very it's
very popular now but instead of storing
your data in in in record oriented for
more basic you'd you'd store one row the
next row the the subsequent row you
store essentially each column in a
different file and it seems like well
why would why would that do faster
there's there's a couple of reasons one
is that column stores are very
compressible so if you say you have like
a very very large number of columns and
you try to compress that data basically
the the compression algorithm it works
by removing redundancy so there's not a
whole lot of redundancy when you go
across a row because all those columns
are actually doing something different
but there's plenty of redundancy when
you go when you go down within a column
so you might you might say say like
countries so country might be might be
one of the row and there might be rows
might be one of the fields and it might
be spelled out everywhere so the this
the but maybe eighty percent of your
your users are in Sweden or in or in the
US so a column with with just a few
distinct values actually compresses very
very nicely so so column score column
stores compressed well and they also
work really nicely with with a
distributed storage system because you
can fetch you can actually read multiple
columns in in parallel without having to
worry that you're you're doing you're
doing disk seeks each time so in if you
have a column store and you have just a
standard spinning spinning disk on your
machine it may not actually be
particularly
fast because you're reading multiple
columns in parallel but each time you
read one column versus the other you're
gonna have to do a disk seek and there's
obviously some read ahead things that
the operating system will do but it's
it's much nicer if you can if you can
read from from distributed storage like
Colossus
what about indexing the Rondo index
isn't bigquery so so you not to worry
about it um so the the question was the
block size in Colossus was is a megabyte
Hadoop sizes are going to much larger to
half a gigabyte what is how is that
gonna affect query times I can't talk
about that very much but all I can say
is is not particularly important the and
I don't want to sound like cocky when I
when I say this but like Google's had
had you know Google build GFS which was
which was which was amazing we had the
GFS paper and that turned into what is
it not HDFS what's the Oh HDFS sorry I
was blanking I was it wasn't you know
implemented implemented externally but
in the meantime we had a lot of
experience running those servers and
running those systems and so they built
Colossus as to solve them to solve the
problems with with GFS so the it's it's
possible that that that did what Hadoop
was doing is is is actually is is better
or larger block sizes larger block sizes
would help but it I think for the most
part it it doesn't and I think and I I
can't go to too much too much more
detail about it unfortunately sorry and
I think you may have some misleading
data about the blossom
decide
I don't but I also don't like getting in
trouble for saying so the question is do
you need four tables a large number of
columns you need do you need to define
sort orders to make the queries fast not
that I know of so I'm not sure why why
you need to do that on Vertica but the
best of my knowledge that doesn't affect
affect bigquery and so maybe maybe with
nested in repeated fields there there
may be some summon there might be some
performance improvements that could be
had had that way but but not not that I
know of always a full scan and so within
caveats so we can be smart about storing
metadata in and we're getting smarter
about storing metadata about what what
data we have to read in every file so
it's possible that we can we can we can
skip some some data so bigquery is an
API it's a JSON API restful JSON API
anybody who who wants to connect to it
can just send us raw HTTP requests with
curl or we have
Google has a technology that takes your
takes your JSON the definition of your
JSON API and it generates clients for in
multiple languages so there's a Python
client there's a Java client c-sharp a
whole bunch of different languages
some people get frustrated that those
clients can be a little bit weird they
may the thing is their since they're
automatically generated from the from
the from the the API definition we don't
have a whole lot of control over over
some certain things so you know the fact
that you have you might have to specify
something as a string rather this then
as an enum and Java it can be a little
bit wonky but it also makes it really
easy just to send send these what-what
turns into JSON requests so anybody can
connect to it but we do we do have a
bunch of first party tools that we that
we provide
there's the bigquery web UI which I
showed which I showed a little while ago
there's the there is a BQ command-line
client some people just don't trust you
eyes and if it doesn't have a you know I
can't do it from their UNIX command
prompt then then it might as well not
exist so so we do we do provide that and
that's also a good way of sort of you
can read the code for that and see what
sort of the best practices are for using
the using bigquery in Python there's
also a connector for Excel so if you
like your Excel spreadsheets you can you
can use that actually you know I I joke
but Excel can be really nice for doing
things like graphing and pivot tables
and stuff and so you can you can just
have your Excel spreadsheet run and run
run against bigquery and update your
graphs it also integrates with with
Google sheets so there's something
called Apps Script which lets you write
scripts against against bigquery and you
can import the data into into your
Google sheets as well for people who are
using Hadoop there's a Hadoop connector
so you can use
query as a source or a sink and then
Google Cloud dataflow is as a new new
technology that allows you to sort of
tie together a bunch of map produces and
in a really sort of nice nice way that
we we can optimize and has lots of nice
nice features and you can also easily
read or write from a bigquery table for
that there's a number of third-party
tools that integrate with bigquery so
tableau is an awesome way of doing data
visualization they did a really good job
they're actually right across the street
from from the the office in Seattle or
we where we work that was fortunate and
so we've been able to work with it work
with them on on their they're connecting
connection to bigquery so people doing
scientific programming they a good
chance they're using our Hadley Wickham
has who's pretty big in the art
community has has written a bigquery
connector for for our if you if you're
into scientific programming and you're
not using our you're probably using
pandas and ipython there's also a nice
connector and I'm actually gonna show
that a little bit later there's ODBC for
people that are more old-school and a
whole bunch of whole bunch of other
things and and additional ones are being
added all the time because how much does
it cost like you know it seems like this
is great thing but we do we do charge
money for it
the first terabyte of data you scan per
month is free that only includes that
includes just the columns that you read
so you might have a a hundred gigabyte
table but if you're with if there's 50
columns and only reading two of those
columns you only have two you're only
charged four for the columns that you
that you read but because we do a full
table scan every time we we do charge
you for the full size of the of the
column it's I did these who there's the
the conversion math before before before
I started these numbers may may
fluctuates I'm not sure what the actual
sort of published rates are published
conversion rates are but it's this is
sort of more or less what you but you
pay
for storing data we charge you on bytes
per month and if you store your data for
less than a month
you only get charged for the for the
actual amount of time that you store
your data rounded down per per second
the other other way you we will we will
get you is if you stream data in will
charge you per ten million rows so it's
not very much per so it's it's one u.s.
dollar per 10 million rows so only it
only it can add up you for doing if
you're doing massive amounts of rows but
that's only for the streaming ingestion
path if you're using the the batch load
which lets you load from google cloud
storage or or via media upload which
allows you to sort of post you post a
large file to to Google that's free
they've come down we started and it was
kind of ridiculously expensive
I won't I won't pass any judgment on
that
certainly not well being recorded but I
think there was the numbers numbers have
come down a lot I would expect them to
come down come down more but we may we
might we might change change them
slightly to make sure that we are
modeling our more active more accurately
modeling our costs the the problem is
you know you want to have a simple a
simple metric by which we can charge
customers but but if we allow customers
to do things that are really expensive
and we only charge them as if they're
not doing those things it can be it can
be a little bit difficult so those
things might change but it it shouldn't
it shouldn't get more expensive unless
you're doing something really abusive
besides the cold best state of
uncompressed data right so so question
was the is it the compress data or the
or the uncompressed data that that your
and and if you're doing a join will it
will we get charged for the the join
outcome so currently it's it's the
recharge for the uncompressed bytes
because with the reasons we charge Leon
your best bytes is that it's predictable
and people know how well their data
compresses we also may rewrite your
table to make it more queryable over
time and that might change the that
might change the size of it on disk and
so if we were charging for the
compression and we change the
compression then the then the cost would
change and people would be like well
wait I have paid a dollar for this last
month and you're charging me a dollar
ten you know why did that happen so we
want to make it we want to make it
predictable but the the join question
was it was an excellent one so you can
do across join two million wrote able to
million wrote a million row table and I
guess a million row table and the the
outcome is a trillion rows that's
clearly going to be difficult for for us
to to to handle and more expensive than
then a million row table so that might
be the kind of thing that might get more
expensive but it shouldn't be not it
shouldn't be in a ridiculous way but I
won't go too much more into into that
it's it's it's a problem it's an open
problem so I talked about this a little
more a little bit more to get your data
in you can load CSV or JSON files from
from Google Cloud Storage you can post
them directly you can also stream
records in you can also send them via
batch ETL through Google Cloud Data
flows or Hadoop or streaming ETL so
dataflow has a streaming API that allows
you to
to do sort of like streaming essentially
streaming mapreduces and it'll it'll
send send those so you can massage the
data as it's coming in and then post
those two to bigquery question I I
shouldn't I don't wanna talk about what
the what what we're working on but I
wouldn't expect that anytime soon
and the questions before you go on this
is just a nice slide that I think Paul
created about how you can how you can
integrate how you can move your data
between between storage locations so you
can if you're if your data is in Google
Cloud datastore there's a datastore
connector for a Hadoop that actually
there's another line that should go to
bigquery that's in a experimental phase
but you can you can backup your data to
to bigquery so we well you can take a
snapshot of your date you have your of
your App Engine data store and import it
into bigquery and you can obviously go
back and forth between Google Cloud
Storage okay so I have one more one more
demo so I'm going to show how see let me
know when you can read this better
there we go hopefully that hopefully all
works so I'm gonna show I had this I
have a playlist data set and and
somebody I found this on on the Internet
and and it was somebody scraped I think
from from from from teaser which I guess
is a French streaming service but anyway
it's it we've got about 12 million songs
in half a million playlists so it's it's
not huge huge data but this would scale
up to up to huge data I hope I convinced
you that with the first the first couple
couple queries that I that I showed so
give you an idea of just what's in this
table we've got we've got the rating
we've got the the title of an album the
the track the artist and the ID of the
playlist and this is stored as a nested
nested data structure when I do this
select star it'll flatten it roll
through all this is it
oh yeah so the next the next thing is is
is okay yeah this just shows how how how
big the data is we've got half a million
playlists 12 million songs so then let's
say we want to compute we're going to do
recommendations we want to do
recommendations by you know one way of
doing that is by is by similarity and
you what you can do is you can compute
the how often do do these two artists
appear in the same playlist together and
you can use that as a as a proxy for if
somebody likes this then they also like
like that
playlists are actually kind of nice in
that people have already curated things
that things that have some sort of
similarity because they might have
they're working out playlists or or or
electronic a playlist that that often
have similar similar bands in them are
artists so here's the here's the query
that that I use for this so so I'm
selecting okay so let's say I'm I'm
joining I'm self joining the playlists
on on ID but where the the artist names
are different so it's actually going to
do a cross join of the or it's going to
generate the cross product of the of
every artist in in a playlist against
every artist that it's different with in
that playlist and so this this is an
example of like so fine artists that are
similar to - Daffy deaf punk and and
sort them by how often they appear they
appear with each other so if you if you
run this query the the results here you
get David Guetta studio group justice
Rihanna weight Rihanna like how is how
is Rihanna like like def def panca so it
might be might be reasonable Chemical
Brothers I guess you know that kind of
makes
but free Queen perhaps perhaps not so
certainly something is is it's not right
here and I wish you didn't have to scan
through all of these it's what happens
when I just say run the entire script
come on I told you I don't do this for a
living and I
aha oh wait no I just went up to the end
sorry this is a
all right there we go so the same thing
okay um so so why didn't we get better
results well and so Amazon likes to give
this as an interview question and they
call it the Harry Potter problem is if
you're trying to do recommendations for
people's like people who like this book
also liked and chances are you're gonna
come up if if you use a naive
recommendation you're gonna come up with
they also like Harry Potter because lots
of people have read Harry Potter but if
you're reading Fifty Shades of Grey you
might not be in the mood for high pot or
vice versa
so so hooli you need to do need
something else and so and so what we
have here is we have the the artists
that come up most are are way too
heavily weighted here so if we look at
at the play counts from four for various
artists we see that a lot of the wait
how are those similar came up studio
group Rihanna Queen our way at the top
and one of these we can show here is
actually is the it's a nice way of
demonstrating that musical artists like
sort of a lot of other letter other
things follow a their popularity follows
a zip or a power-law distribution
meaning that it's a fat-tailed
distribution but that the the the the
further you go out if really go to the
left you jump up very very quickly it's
a really poor description of that but
it's gonna have to do for today but
that's what that that's what that looks
like and so we we we fit actually really
nicely to as if distribution I actually
I I took out the most of the tail to
this anything with the play count of
less than fifty because otherwise you
wouldn't even be able to see the blue
line on the corner there so one of the
things that we can do is is one of the
things you want to do you do often when
you're when you're writing complex
queries is you start with a simple query
and or you start with a couple simple
queries and then you can combine them so
what I'm doing is since so there was
another problem with the with the the
the naive query which was that a lot of
artists will show up multiple times in a
single playlist and we were sort of
waiting things to strongly we wait
so if if an artist showed up twice in a
playlist we'd wait them double against
things that showed up in that same
playlist and so we probably don't want
to don't want to do that especially
since a lot of people may put you know a
whole bunch of you know all the same
tracks from an album and in a playlist
and and those shouldn't get more wait so
we can do as a computer sub query of the
the unique artists that are that show up
and put in a playlist so we can sort of
save this off as sort of the unique
artists and then we can compute the
similarity by unique artist within it
within a playlist so this is this is
similar to that same query that I ran at
the beginning but but it's instead of
running against the raw table I'm
running against this sort of this unique
artist value and I'm limiting limiting
to two things that show up more than
more than twenty times just because it's
not all that useful to say something is
is similar to something that's only been
played 20 times like that that doesn't
doesn't make so much difference so so
then how do we so we have one more one
more step and then we actually have the
weekend we can get a better better
simular similarity and so what we'll do
is we we we join we join the similarity
output against the against the play
counts and we we scale the the
similarity by the play count and you can
actually think of this is what we're
doing
is we're computing the percent of the
time that if you have one artist that
that other artist will also appear in
the in the same playlist and we do it
from the similar artist to the artist
because that also helps helps prevent
the the Rihanna problem so let's see
let's see how we do here make sure this
is live so we've got jay-z so I didn't
know how they were gonna spell jay-z so
I just did it contains here which is
also one nice thing with bigquery is
that you know in a relational database
you might need to do an exact as I
extreme match because it was going to
need to read on an index this you could
just do I could do a regular expression
I can do just a string containment here
so what are the what do we get here we
got Farrell Busta Rhymes biggie so these
are these are pretty reasonable so try
try something somebody totally different
Andrew bird popular indie artist plays
plays like six instruments at once
pretty amazing amazing guy see what see
who's what similar to - Andrew bird
survey says come on it's kind of thing
that loves to happen when you're doing a
demo
go blame this on being a 3,000 miles
away from our servers they missed me all
right that that's way longer that should
take
there we go so who we got here we've got
a bunch of people I don't recognize bon
iver Sufjan Stevens fleet Fleet Foxes
Belle and Sebastian the national it's a
bunch of these things you know seem
Beirut seem kind of kind of similar and
then there's a Swedish artist named Kent
that's right try this one I want I mean
I'll be able to tell whether anybody is
is is similar or not but you guys may be
able to there we go
anybody seem similar yes no okay
anyway I have other suggestions
they don't know anything we were there
Spelling do they I think we're we're
than they do with their music
oh no yeah is it is it it's all caps
looks like somebody thinks they here we
go bo diddley I'm not sure I'd
necessarily agree with these but
shangri-la's this might be might be
similar anyway at least today we can see
that it's we it's better than better
than the than the original one anyway
that's um they came from somebody had
posted a done a blog post about using
using bigquery to to do to ask some
questions about about music database and
I guess they had they had ingested these
from from Deezer and and he actually had
there were a couple sample sample
queries that were doing sort of a naive
way and I'm like I bet I can do better
than that
so hopefully I can then contribute those
back anyway
that's all that's all I have